vampire chicken
60
three minute
standard
standard three minute
okay
mental note i'm starting with less time
get out of your five-minute mentality
right here here we go
okay
e4 for the win
okay french defense
and let's go with the wino r
okay now that
let's go here
f4 knight f3
bishop e3
queen d2
actually knight a4 in response to queen
b6 i should have played that in that
earlier game so
where does my bishop want to be
let's go queen d2
queen d2 to f2 in fact um
i'm gonna play g3
this is actually a bit uh scary to do
this
because the knight might get the bright
id to land on c4
right i do have to be cautious um with
g3 i'm saying okay i want my bishop on
g2
but but pop pop
um the c4 square is definitely weakened
i'm gonna play here
just to reinforce d4 and i am in a
position to play b3
to watch over the c4 square okay now
what direction should i go in
i think i like this pawn move
let's develop here first f5 i would love
to get in
um with the knight f4 continuation maybe
just even a pawn sack
okay i think i'm better now because
i have this pawn break in successfully i
wonder if this was somehow a mouse slip
maybe it was g6 that was meant to be
played
now this is big trouble because of the
light squares
take here now knight f4 right away
on the pawn and this point right here
kingside castle my rook is contributing
and if my knight cannot be dislodged
from this square i think there's some
serious issues for black and
i'm seeing it be the case that it's
going to be a while before it could be
dislodged because
i can connect my knights knight g6 i'm
going to do it right now knight g6 if
it's challenged with knight here i could
follow up with knight h4
no need to do it right now though
not until it is first challenged so in
the meantime let me play over here
looking to play on both wings open up
the b file
i think going with the a pawn is the
best way
if i capture then there we go half open
a file
if this capture occurs then it's going
to be a wide open b file let me go with
this
okay and actually let me just make
certain of no pawn push in the night
getting here
i don't want this square
to be made use of so
what could i do to make progress my dark
square bishop needs some help
where's my queen wanna be
where would my queen where's a dream
square for my queen
hmm
well actually what's wrong with just
doubling rooks
now i'm going to do this with the idea
of queen h3 knight f4 i think it could
be very uncomfortable to defend this
pawn
what gets done with that now
okay let's keep still think i keep that
knight right here
maybe
i um
yeah that's a pretty smooth move right
there okay so let me take
and um
and put pressure on that pawn
yeah it comes just in the nick of time i
think or no actually my night's hit what
am i doing
let's do this i guess my night's long
gone
but my queen is active and this knight
is still homeless
just kind of hanging out there
so maybe there was something with
getting my pawn up here to secure my
knights position i probably should have
looked into that but
i i still think this is advantageous
even though my bishop is kind of bad can
i get it over here
hmm
i think now the time
now is the time to double
pressure on the knight
now that there's a disconnect between
the rooks i think if i maybe did that a
bit earlier there would be just all the
heavy pieces coming off the board
but these guys are not on the same rank
anymore difficult to meet the rook moves
to these squares
so let me retreat to a square that's
going to be
no why retreat
i could take this safely
actually no let's come back
21 seconds
pound push queen h4 and bishop on f4
locks everything
probably get my other rook over here
maybe my queen could she swing over in
this direction
um
i'm gonna try that actually
look up check right here
tripled up
the king can't run away now my queen is
sneaking in my bishop maybe even
dark square
pin knight
i could have just taken the knight that
would have been mate
or really close to it when i moved my
queen right there that should have been
me
right here rook there
instead of the queen move i could take
the knight i missed that okay good game
that was interesting let's see um i
don't know
right here let's see
i don't know about my moves right here
the
the knight going back actually right
here i don't know about the g3 move
but um i just i think this is a typical
lift sometimes i think there might be a
queen f2
putting more pressure on this pawn
forcing it to do something
but um
and this tension releasing the tension i
don't know about that
like how about just um
capture
and then maybe try and get your knight
to this e4 square
i wonder if that's a
i wonder if he could be running with
something like that
but anyhow there's no tension in the
center so now i'm going to be looking to
play on the king side and i don't know
where black should be going with their
king
you go queen side it's a little bit airy
these puns are a little bit over
extended and i do have some play on the
a or b file with that starting with that
a3 move
and right here i think playing g6
is maybe a better
way to
do things
as soon as i get this break in i'm
feeling pretty good
g6 maybe i didn't
play it as well
maybe um h4 h5
is an idea clamping down on this square
i don't know my opponent did well to
neutralize that knight though black
certainly identified where i have uh
a well-placed pieces and it definitely
is the knight
in black's territory right here on g6
if there's if the knight is able to sit
here these rooks never get to contest
this f-file that's the
that's one way to translate this
knight's position on g6 if he sticks
around here he's watching f8
if he's watching f8 your rooks can't do
much
on the f file at least
maybe it is best to actually play king
here and look for
one pair of rooks to come off the board
if i'm able to keep two on the board
there's i think
well i think two rooks is just
too much for you to
cope with
okay
so i got pushed around a little bit but
we were both moving crazy at that point
no not very much thought going into it
from then on so okay let me close out